so I've got my Zen one in my Zen
takeaway said one so now let's think
about where the arguments are in this
diagram right what is at least on the
diagram as I have it
what is Alexander said one well maybe I
should say where is ugh
Zim I said one because I'm still
thinking in terms of the origin right
you guys from the origin all right you
take the positive real axis and then up
you guys there's the angle okay with
that that's the argument of Z minus n1
now the question then becomes where else
is that angle where else is the angle
well I'm gonna take advantage of a
parallelogram again right I'm gonna put
up the side of you here I don't really
need this size that's my goal
gonna save you completeness okay now
remember this green angle Phi of Z minus
ed one is measured from a horizontal
it's mention measure from the positive
real axis so I kind of need another
positive real axis but I'm shifting my
point of reference okay shifting my
point of reference so therefore if I put
in a positive real axis that comes as it
were off of z1 that's where my new
measurement point is okay do you see
based on like this line and this line of
parallel because it's a parallelogram
right here yeah yeah and then you've got
a a one it's parallel to your parallel
so where else is the angle and saw
surely it's here do you see it if my my
lines are reasonable in straightness
okay so if I've got the same argument
down here our Z minus z1
that's from or and the positive real
axis op to Zi minus N 1
let me get that first definition
okay so I guess the way I would say it
is the aims measured at that point then
from the positive real axis go with that
but this guy in blue here which is the
same magnitude or the same size I should
say that argument is the same anger
there has nothing to do with the origin
like how would you win it what angle is
it it's the angle measured at z1 right
said one and where is its funny point
well it's not the positive real axis
anymore that's all the way down here but
it's a victor for them it's the free
vector of the positive real axis do you
see the positive real axis is a position
vector right it's just starting from her
and then off it goes right so what
you've got is an equivalent free vector
just moved up to you a new point of
reference and that's where you measure
from measured from and everything say
it's from zip 1 because I just said it's
from day one okay
this green one is I'm thinking about z
takeaways in one as a point over there
and this blue one is actually thinking
about zip that's where it's actually
looking with any point of reference okay
so now if I asked you just like I did
before
what if I said what is the locus of
points such of the argument of that
point takeaway said one is equal to PI
on 2
what I want is this way of thinking
right said what's my point of reference
and when I measure from the horizontal
right from the positive real axis up to
whichever cumbersome as you want that
said I want to get planetary radians
it's 90 degrees right I can't draw that
set here's a point that'll give me a
right angle
yeah here's another point that'll still
give me the right angle in fact anywhere
upwards from here will give me that
angle does that make sense yeah I'll get
to that in a second so you can see any
of these points right Zed wants my new
point of reference yes there was many
pretty records so therefore any of these
points up here will measure PI on - when
I think about their argument okay
correct it's exactly right okay so all
of these points have an argument of piyo
- measured from z1 okay now the question
becomes what about zip one about zip one
now we don't have to guess actually I
don't have to guess because if I test
out z1 yeah when I test out
Zed equals Zed one what I find is okay
if the audio is that one takeaway said
one which is the argument at the origin
which is undefined right so therefore
said what itself is not included in the
lawyers
yeah the oranges well as it was the new
point of reference rightly is shifting
the point of reference so therefore he
becomes this in the origin as okay
yes if you want to think about it yeah
how would you draw the locus of points
quite difficult because like if you're
in the considered sense yes that one yes
obviously yes I cannot I'll tell you how
you need to do it you would think okay
I've got I've got a point
Zed one right when I subtract said one
that's going this direction right so
therefore Z is actually in the opposite
direction like the actual Z I've got a
sort of reverse engineer as it were okay
so what I would do is I would say okay
well all the arguments plants who are up
here right so then you take every single
one of these points and you would
translate it in Reverse so you would add
Xen one to us which would take you over
there and then over there and then over
there right would you give you all of
these points